jack it is wonderful to see you uh i'm
here in vancouver and it's a little bit
chilly and it looks like
it's nice and warm where you are um what
does it mean for you as an actor to
finally release this blockbuster film
after a whirlwind
of a year for everybody yeah it's been
amazing it's been quite the journey we
finished the movie in 2018 so i've been
waiting some time
uh to to get it out there into cinemas
and it was so exciting last night we had
the world premiere
i saw it on a big screen in a cinema i
hadn't been in the cinema for over a
year and a half and to be there
sharing that communal experience and to
see the movie
finally with all of the cgi and the
music for the first time it was a really
special experience
now i understand you and emily teased uh
dwayne while you guys were making this
film by sending videos of his uh
stunts and making i think he had
nicknames for each other was this stunty
blunty stunts
man is that right yeah jackson man
that's the one i sort of gave myself
and then dwayne was toots yeah we kind
of ripped him a little bit he's great he
doesn't take himself too seriously and
uh
i think that's uh you know testament to
dwayne johnson the man is that he's
uh got such a great sense of humor and
uh yeah we were able to have a lot of
fun on set
did he respond in any way uh
yeah i mean there was a lot of like
stealing each other's phones
um uh trying to put each other off
during
takes uh remember there was one day
where
dwayne wasn't on set and we had like a
a plastic uh version of his head that
was used in one of the scenes and
me and emily took quite a lot of
photographs with the plastic dwayne
johnson head and sent them to him
some of which would probably not be
sanctioned by disney
you know what i love your character
because i have a brother too and i was
thinking about my brother would he ever
do anything crazy for me the way you did
uh for lily uh you have a sister have
you ever been in a situation where she's
like
you gotta do this for me yeah
i yeah molly my sister is great and
she's you know
on occasion she's asked me to do favors
for her but she's never
as of yet suggested that we head up the
amazon river
in the search of the tree of life and
risk our lives fighting off
mercenaries and undead conquistadors but
you know were she too
i would probably oblige
or suggest that maybe she went and
sought some psychiatric help
and you know one of the things watching
this film too um there's a lot of snakes
and i have a fear of snakes i'm
wondering do you have any fears of
snakes or
insects or animals or anything yeah i
mean i do have a fear of snakes and i
watched it last night and i walked out
and i went the bit with the snakes is
quite scary you know i have a fear of
snakes
and someone was like yeah but there's
snakes in other movies like
indiana jones that are kind of like
family friendly and i was like oh yeah
there are
snakes in indiana jones i remember that
now and then i was like maybe that's why
i'm afraid of snakes
because of those formulative experiences
of watching those movies and seeing
snakes in them and getting scared
and i think it's so great that jungle
cruise is going to do that for a whole
new generation of children
right we're going to give right a whole
new
generation of children a fear of snakes
thank you for making this movie i can't
wait for my kids to see it it is
absolutely brilliant and i can't wait to
go to disney one day soon and
uh thank you so much jack thank you very
much lovely to chat to you
you